hi I'm Matt Welch him with my co-author
Nick Gillespie of the Declaration of
Independence the libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America that
is supposed to come out jun 28 but we've
seen it in stores around town we're here
on ask a libertarian day talk about the
booking ideas in it and the next
question comes from David atkin Ellsberg
um and we've had a lot like this as a
longtime party member i presume this is
the Libertarian Party that he's
discussing I felt that libertarians have
never been able to articulate a foreign
policy position that did not come across
as extremely isolationist and out of
touch with reality to the point that
some libertarians believe that we
wouldn't even have embassies and
diplomats do they think the president is
going to handle all of this by himself
Nick well unfortunately the president
has most recently taken foreign policy
on all by himself with the invasion of
Libya which I don't think its isolation
is to say that that is a really stupid
idea and the days not weeks have now
turned into months and I suspect will be
half years and years going down the road
I do think you know waving aside the
question about embassies and things like
that most libertarians I know are not
isolationist they are
non-interventionist they understand that
generally speaking military intervention
accomplishes far less than what we think
it does I think that there are better
types of engagement that come through
cultural open and you massive cultural
exchange probably first and foremost an
economic exchange but there is
definitely a role for military
intervention i think that United States
participation in world war two was
absolutely called for I think once you
get away from that in the 20th century
it does become harder to justify but
when there are actual national interests
at risk when there is a clear mission
that is articulated and signed off on by
Congress not simply by one or two people
in the American government I think the
military you know it makes sense to have
one and it makes sense to use one in
those rare but important circumstances
one of the basic principles of
libertarianism is non coercion
non-interventionism the idea is that
you're not going to try to force someone
to do something that you want them to do
in general that and a notion of
self-defense someone punches you in the
face you might want to punch them back
and have an organized process for doing
that I think that is sort of the bed
rock from which that debate within the
Libertarian Party among libertarians
Springs there are some who are
completely anti interventionist in every
case and don't even want to talk about
bad things happening in foreign
countries because that is a prelude
somehow to having a hyper intervention
either way I think we have a moment
right now where there's a long overdue
critique in American politics where
we're way overextended it has come to a
very ridiculous point where the world
turns to America for everything
especially when it's time to shoot a gun
or or or suppress someone that we don't
like and that needs to come back we
can't afford it it's breeding a flagrant
irresponsibility among everybody else
and and we have to change that system
yeah I think it's also worth pointing
out that we can't afford it economically
we pay you know six times more than the
second largest country in terms of
defense dollars which is China but we
can't afford it economically it's
bankrupting us but it's also bankrupt
bankrupting us morally because if we
become the world's policeman it means
that we're patrolling every fruit stand
in the around the globe and we get into
a lot of really sticky situations as
opposed to holding our powder for the
places where we need to be other
countries should be shouldering their
burdens particularly when it comes to
regional conflicts there's no reason
that Japan and China can't be handling
North Korea for instance